ti est ce que il ya eu un manque de
pédagogie vous disiez quand cette
version est arrivée elle est un peu
arrivé sur la tête de tout le monde sans
qu'on comprenne vraiment pourquoi est ce
que c'est le péché originel de cette
fois travail ou escales inverse
de toute façon ça n'aurait rien changé
on se souvient que la loi ce qu'en
soirée permet elle a été négociée très
très très longtemps pour finalement être
pas mal vidé de sa substance au final et
je crois qu'il ya une triple faute
défaut de concertation très clairement
au moins un des articles quand on by au
canal des éléments non tous les autres
j'en suis témoin était négocié y compris
avec les organisations syndicales mais
l'article sur les licenciements n'a pas
été aussi première faute deuxième faute
c'est de laisser à penser que nous
allions travailler sur le code du
travail comme si le code du travail
c'était l'outil qui empêchait ou qui
permettait de créer des emplois est une
faute parce que le droit du travail est
là pour réguler les relations entre les
salariés et puis les employeurs et puis
la troisième faute c'est d'avoir laissé
à penser que ce texte allait être un
texte qu'elle et créer de l'emploi il
est pas là pour créer l'emploi il est là
pour tenir compte de l'évolution du
monde du travail parce que le monde du
travail à bouger personne ne peut dire
le contraire
et cette triple faute eh bien nous la
portons malheureusement et je crois que
c'est un des éléments quand ça démarre
mal ça démarre mal